Insane.
Pathetic, a disgrace.
I'm S.E. Cupp. Welcome to Unfiltered.
Believe it or not.
Those were the words right
wing voices used to describe
Donald Trump's attack on his own.
Former press secretary
Kayleigh McEnany this week.
In case you missed it,
McEnany went on Fox News,
where she is now
a contributor
to discuss
the Republican primary polls and noted
that Trump was polling at 34%
in Iowa in April
and is now down to 25%,
according to McLaughlin and Associates,
Trump's preferred pollster.
Her former boss didn't like that,
so he took to Truth Social blasting
the woman who supported him dutifully
since 2017 first
as Republican
National Committee spokeswoman and later
as his press secretary,
Kayleigh Milquetoast
McEnany just gave out
the wrong poll numbers on Fox News,
Trump wrote
I am 34 points up on the sanctimonious
not 25 up.
Well, 25 is great it's not 34.
She knew the number was corrected
upwards by the group that did that poll.
Notably, McLaughlin
does not appear
to have corrected the poll that McEnany
accurately cited.
But Trump concluded his post,
saying the rhinos
and globalists can have her.
Fox News should only use real stars.
It was a brutal swipe
at someone who was just doing her job.
So brutal, in fact,
that many on the right
came to her defense.
Newsmax host
Rob Finnerty said,
I don't like it,
especially with someone like Kayleigh
McEnany who's seemingly
so loyal to her former boss.
Fox News host
Brian Kilmeade called it insane.
Blaze TV host Chad Prather called it
pathetic, unacceptable. And unhinged.
Trump's former deputy
director of communications,
Matt Woking, called it a disgrace.
And Fox News political
analyst Brit Hume tweeted Imagine being
so immature as to attack
your former press secretary
who was nothing
if not loyal
for allegedly misquoting a poll number.
This backlash against Trump from
the right is remarkable
for a few reasons. One.
Obviously, Kayleigh
McEnany is very well-liked,
so well-liked
that those in conservative
circles
are willing to attack him, to defend her.
I had the pleasure of working with Kelly
while she was a pundit here at CNN.
And while we disagreed often,
she was smart,
prepared, thoughtful,
kind and a total pro.
And I second
all the kind words said about her.
But it's also revealing
that Trump is no longer above reproach,
even among those who once supported him.
Attacking
McEnany was obviously an indignity,
not worth suffering
for a political movement
that suffered happily
through plenty of them.
But the
takeaway for me is bigger than Kayleigh.
What this says is
that Trump can go too far
in shooting inside the tent,
a presidential opponent like Senator
Tim Scott of South Carolina, for example,
who is very well-liked in Congress,
the Republican Party and his home state
won't be easy for Trump to attack,
especially if he doesn't dirty.
As we all know he can.
Look,
I'm sure Trump
has plenty of fight left in him,
but Kelly might just be a canary in the
coal mine.
That's it for me. See you next week.